we begin with this because we're
learning new information about Geoffrey
Epstein's final days three more of his
alleged victims are suing his estate the
lawsuits filed overnight indicate how
Epstein and his associates allegedly
used young woman's financial worries to
pull them into a web of sexual abuse and
CBS News has confirmed that confirmed
the convicted sex offender filed the
will in the US Virgin Islands where he
owned a home just two days before his
suicide in a New York City jail cell
first on CBS this morning we're hearing
from one of the attorneys involved in
these new lawsuits Willa legi is
following this story for us
good morning mullet what are we learning
well good morning guys the contents of
these lawsuits are well frankly they're
a bit overwhelming one even alleges that
following his 2008 conviction on child
prostitution prostitution charges in
Florida
Epstein used his work release program as
a front for more sexual abuse victims
attorneys tell us that this is not just
about going after the multimillionaires
fortune but getting justice for the
women whose lives he allegedly ruined we
want to hold the UPS teen organization
to account first it's not primarily
about money stan Pottinger represents 20
Jeffrey Epstein accusers including the
three women who filed civil lawsuits
overnight all of them are against the
Epstein estate and various companies
that he had as part of his scheme or
syndicate or the organization that he
had that helped him round up girls
the lawsuit brought by Lisa doe claims
an Epstein associate hired Lisa than 17
to teach a dance based exercise class at
Epstein's townhouse in later
interactions Epstein allegedly solicited
massages used a sex toy on her forcibly
and ultimately demanded that she go to
her dance studio and find other dancers
the lawsuit filed by Caitlin Dome
alleges Epstein sexually abused her when
she was 17 and coerced her to lose her
virginity to him after she turned 18 it
also claims Epstein forced her to marry
an associate who wasn't a US citizen so
they could stay in the country to
recruit more girls and the lawsuit
brought by Priscilla Doe who was 20 when
she first met Epstein is the only one to
name his purported ex
girlfriend turned business associate
d'Alene Maxwell Priscilla claims Maxwell
taught her the proper way to sexually
please Epstein while on a trip to his
island in the Caribbean and alleges
Epstein at one point confiscated her
passport so she couldn't leave the
island voluntarily Priscilla's lawsuit
also mentioned some of Epstein's
powerful friends
she says she once met the Sultan of
Dubai with Epstein and on another
occasion was forced to serve hors
d'oeuvres at a private party Epstein had
with director Woody Allen all three
lawsuits
take aim Epstein's fortune which his
will filed two days before his death
reveals to be worth nearly 578 million
dollars Epstein's brother mark
is the only listed air after Epstein
suicide the criminal sex trafficking
charges against him effectively died but
Pottinger says the pursuit of justice is
very much alive but I think the
government while it has been taken off
track briefly by this untimely death I
think that they're not giving up we
should mention that ghilane Maxwell is
not charged with a crime it has denied
recruiting women or any wrongdoing for
Epstein in the past now these new
lawsuits come after Attorney General
William bar yesterday removed the Acting
Director of the Bureau of Prisons amid
mounting evidence of irregularities at
the facility where Epstein was held
before his apparent suicide Tony mola
highly disturbing details to put it
lightly really in these new allegations
at the same time prosecutors here in New
York have dropped criminal charges
against Epstein or moved to do so what
does that mean going forward well even
if those charges are dropped
prosecutors could also pursue Epstein's
co-conspirators the other alleged people
who allegedly have done crimes they can
pursue them with criminal charges
otherwise these civil cases are really
the main avenue for recourse for the
victims like this morning's lawsuit that
was just filed and again that's amid
multiple federal investigations that
we're seeing unfold so the pursuit of
justice continues it does yeah death
does not stop this case it still goes on
many many questions
good to see you MoMA - thanks bola